bonsoir à tous bienvenue à 24,60 10
décembre journée internationale des
droits de l'homme ou sa porte encore le
nom de droits de l'homme pour les
nations unies ça fait marquant de cette
journée la décision de la haute cour
britannique d'extrader le cofondateur de
wikileaks vers les états unis julian
assange est accusé d'espionnage là
dessus on écoute sa conjointe l'avocate
stella maurice
approuvent l'action du chimiste
a nice comme des chiens
ok mais accepte
d'escosse de fans de manson press
freedom a notamment pressé
fight
le combat de julian assange a commencé
en 2010 avec la diffusion par wikileaks
de documents classifiés sur la guerre en
irak et en afghanistan en décembre la
même année il est arrêté à londres et
pendant 7 ans du clown assange se
réfugier à l'ambassade d'équateur allons
toujours en avril 2019 il est finalement
arrêté par la police britannique puis
emprisonné aujourd'hui la justice
britannique a autorisé son extradition
vers les états unis où on a compris que
le combat allait continuer alors qu'est
ce qu'ils attendent ou le massage j'ai
fait le point avec son avocat maître
anthony vais un peu plus tôt que j'ai
joint
cotonou au bénin
m v depuis le bénin depuis cotonou merci
d'être avec nous pour réagir à la
décision de la haute cour britannique
d'extrader votre client d'où la
naissance aux états unis on vient
d'entendre sa femme elle-même avant 4
c'était là maurice tu disais qu'elle va
continuer le combat que risquent
maintenant du liana chant assange
je crois que les mots de sa compagne ont
été très très fort il risque deux choses
la première c'est un procès qui peut pas
être un procès équitable aux états unis
parce que depuis onze ans il souffre de
cette persécution politique dont il est
victime et tous les observateurs
internationaux qui ont pu le voir l'on
dit il à une faiblesse une fragilité de
santé aujourd'hui qui ne lui permettent
plus de faire face à cette procédure est
évidemment s'il était extradé en dépit
des garanties que soutiennent les états
unis non seulement ils ne pourraient pas
avoir un procès équitable mais serait en
plus soumis à un traitement inhumain et
dégradant
c'est pour ça que comme stella maurice
claudie on a raison de se battre et que
chaque génération doit se battre temps
quelque chose et qu'effectivement notre
génération doit se bat pour ça parce que
c'est le le droit à être informés qui
est en cause ouais viola n'a changé ses
alliés internationaux même jusqu'aux
nations unies ont toujours défendu que
julian assange pratiquer le journalisme
en diffusant des documents et des vidéos
on va représenter cette vidéo absolument
dramatique est au coeur même de ces
accusations diffus d en 2010 avec le
soutien ou la participation de chelsea
manning cette vidéo on voit des soldats
américains tuer des civils irakiens
jouent en gagnera messieurs les maisons
c'est une vidéo qui fait très mal à
regarder mais c'est le genre
d'information que jo dan assange voulait
diffuser les violations des conventions
internationales
on regarde cette vidéo
julian assange a eu au fil des années
beaucoup depuis internationaux
aujourd'hui on apprend que même des
députés français souhaiterait qu'ils le
trouvent asile trouvent refuge en france
pour contrer cette extradition aux états
unis quelles sont les autres options sur
le plan international où sont ces
j'appuie maintenant
il a reçu le soutien de beaucoup de
démocrates en allemagne en suisse en
france dans beaucoup de pays et je veux
dire que le soutien populaire qu'il
qu'il a est immense
malheureusement pas celui des démocrates
américains et il faut se souvenir que en
réalité tout part de là donc il n'ya
qu'une pression internationale forte sur
l'exécutif américain qui pourra faire en
sorte que cette persécution s'arrête
sinon elle va continuer à apprendre
différentes formes ça fait déjà onze ans
que julian assange se bat lille est à
bout de force il est épuisé et
aujourd'hui il n'y a que un réveil
populaire j'ai envie de dire comparable
à celui qui avait pu avoir pour nelson
mandela qui est capable d'enrayer ce
processus funeste
les la demande d'extradition les
nombreuses accusations contre julian a
change donc porte sur la révélation de
documents classifiés confidentiels sur
la guerre en irak et en afghanistan les
états unis les procureurs américains
plein que monsieur assange a mis en
péril la sécurité nationale
vu deux sources importantes pour la
défense nationale qu'avez vous répondu à
cet argument
[Musique]
il faut que vous sachiez que cet
argument a été finalement
retirés par les états unis puisqu'ils
ont été dans l'incapacité de démontrer
qu effectivement des personnes physiques
avaient été mis en danger donc le débat
s'est déplacé comme c'est toujours le
cas dans le dossier assange dès qu'un
argument on va dire est fallacieux et
mis en évidence les états unis changent
pour un autre argument donc non monsieur
assange n'a pas mis en danger des
personnes et n'a pas mis en danger du
personnel diplomatique il n'a fait que
révéler des informations vraies les
espionnages de dirigeants étrangers par
les états unis les crimes de guerre
commis par les militaires américains sur
des civils et aujourd'hui il est
poursuivi uniquement pour avoir révélé
des informations vraies je rappelle que
ces informations étaient divulguées par
wikileaks en partenariat avec tous les
plus grands quotidiens internationaux
dans le monde entier et qu'aujourd'hui
il est le seul qui depuis deux ans
croupit en prison comme s'il était un
terroriste ou un prisonnier de guerre ce
qu'il n'est pas c'est un homme de paix
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a jamais prêché la
violence et aujourd'hui il devrait être
à minima placé sous contrôle judiciaire
pour préparer sa défense
les les états unis vous propose vous
offre des garanties qu'ils seraient
traités humainement s'il était extradé
qu'il ne serait plus là dans une prison
normale je le dis en guise mais qu'il ne
serait pas mal traités et qu'il pourrait
éventuellement purger sa peine en
australie son pays d'origine vous
réfutez vous n'acceptez pas les
garanties offertes par les procureurs
américains
en fait ce que vous me dites me fait
froid dans le dos quand je sais que j'ai
visités moi-même julian assange à la
prison de belmarsh et que c'est un
individu qui aujourd'hui est un fantôme
absolument dans la difficulté de se
concentrer il est complètement esseulé
depuis plus de deux ans donc l'idée que
parce qu'il ne va pas finir dans un camp
mais dans une prison dite de haute
sécurité on offre des garanties à cet
homme je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui il n'a
jamais été condamné et il n'a jamais été
jugé et que pourtant ça fait onze ans
qu'il n'a pas vu la lumière du jour
encore une fois pour avoir commis un
crime qui n'existe pas à savoir avoir
révélé la vérité donc j'espère que tous
les journalistes tous les citoyens qui
écoutent cette émission se rendent
comptent qu'aujourd'hui c'est leur droit
à être informés qui est en jeu c'est
leur droit à avoir accès à une
information vraie crédible et qui met en
cause des gouvernants américains parce
que ce sont eux qui dans ces cas là et
elle est criminelle donc aujourd'hui
c'est criminel la faune de julian
assange leurs victimes depuis plusieurs
années et malheureusement ce processus
judiciaire n'a pas connu son épilogue ce
soir mais comme l'a dit stella maurice
et comme le demande julian assange nous
allons continuer à nous battre la cour
l'a autres semblent refusé l'argument de
la de l'association au dad enfin l'as
les questions de santé mentale de votre
client bon d'autun qui la fondent une
famille alors qu'il était réfugié à
l'ambassade d'équateur qui elle a eu
deux enfants
pourquoi la cour n'accepte pas cet
argument ou pourquoi devrait-elle
accepté cet argument
alors la cour d'appel n'a absolument pas
remis en cause la décision du juge
britannique sur cet argument là et je
crois qu'aucun observateur de ce dossier
ne peut contester que julian assange est
aujourd'hui dans un état psychique et
psychiatriques extrêmement délabré le
rapporteur spécial des nations unies
parlent de persécution et de torture
institutionnels dans ce dossier je crois
que aucune institution n'a remis en
cause ce constat et c'est ça aussi toute
la difficulté du dossier d'assange c'est
de constater qu'un homme torturé à ciel
ouvert sous couvert d'une procédure
judiciaire qui est complètement
instrumentalisée donc il faut que
l'opinion publique le comprennent il
faut qu'ils se rendent compte de la
réalité de cette torture et il faut
arrêter de penser que parce qu'un homme
effectivement essaye de s'accrocher à la
bi en fondant une famille pour autant il
n'est pas torturé il n'a pas vu la
lumière du jour depuis 11 ans il n'a
aucun contact avec ses proches il est
incapable de parler à la presse donc oui
c'est un homme qui est esseulé et qui
aujourd'hui sous une torture qui n'a
aucune justification
vous avez cité le rapporteur spécial sur
la torture excellent manqué dick
souffle enfin qu'il subit que son
incarcération et un caractère cruel
arbitraire inhumains et dégradants
cela dit est ce qu'il ya des voies de
négociation possible
je prends l'exemple des doigts de
snowdon qu'il dit je retournerai aux
états unis si j'avais la garantie d'un
procès public or il n'a pas ces
garanties le gouvernement barack obama
avec avait commué la peine de chelsea
manning avec laquelle
monsieur assange a publié ces fameuses
vidéos et documents est ce qu'il ya des
voies de négociation possible selon de
médiation possible
non mais la différence c'est que je suis
à 100 je ne reconnais absolument pas les
faits pour lesquels il est poursuivi
monsieur à 100 je n'étais pas un
fonctionnaire de l'administration
américaine monsieur à changes n'a pas
aidé à la diffusion de ces vidéos ces
vidéos lui ont été remises par le biais
d'une plateforme qui sécurise les
sources et aujourd'hui il n'est
uniquement poursuivi que pour la
publication de ces vidéos est évidemment
monsieur assange n'a absolument rien à
voir avec la justice américaine en
réalité les états unis et monsieur
assange ont mené un combat idéologique
pendant plus de dix ans et pour
incarcérer monsieur assange et le faire
taire on a transformé ce combat
politique ont un combat judiciaire pour
l'instant pour les états unis cette
stratégie a été payante mais le cas
assange n'a rien à voir sur le fond avec
lesquels vous vous les décrire sauf
qu'ils interrogent sur notre rapport est
plutôt sur le rapport de dirigeants
américains avec la vérité
des coïncidences dans la vie dans
l'histoire je vous joins compte ni alors
que vous défendez une femme politique
qui a voulu
défendre ses convictions et qui est
accusé de certains contenus et par
contre on est aussi aujourd'hui 10
décembre journée internationale de ce
qu'on appelle encore les droits de
l'homme ici on les appelle les droits de
la personne les droits de l'homme
en quoi cette soie de julian assange
peut être un symbole justement de
l'importance de défendre les droits de
l'homme
c'est le symbole actuel de notre époque
sur la défense des droits de l'homme
d'abord parce que dont les droits de
l'homme il ya effectivement cette
liberté d'informer sans laquelle on ne
peut pratiquer la démocratie sans avoir
accès à une information fiable
transparente qui nous permet d'exercer
notre sens critique tous nos droits
démocratiques ne sont que de vaines
promesses et deuxièmement il ya aussi la
dignité d'un homme le fait que ne soit
jamais soumis à un traitement inhumain
et dégradant ça aussi c'est dans les
droits de l'homme comme on les appelle
et je peux vous dire que depuis plus de
dix ans la personne de julian assange
est soumis à un traitement inhumain et
dégradant tu donc les droits de l'homme
est un objectif pour lequel les gens de
bonne volonté se bat au quotidien et il
est malheureux que en ce jour
d'anniversaire des droits de l'homme
malheureusement nous ayons a commenté
une si triste décision mais encore une
fois c'est un combat un combat que doit
relever notre génération pour faire en
sorte que les gens comme vous les
journalistes qui diffusait des
informations vraies ne puisse jamais
être persécutés par un pouvoir exécutif
parce que les informations qui sont
diffusées lui déplaisent
antoine veil avocat de julian assange
est aussi avocat
de réckya madougou accusé en ce moment
au bénin vous avez quitté la cour
aujourd'hui en enlevant votre jauge
protestant contre la dépendance du
tribunal on croit comprendre que c'est
vraiment le combat de votre vie que de
défense
de défendre des personnes contre les
abus commis à leur endroit merci
beaucoup antoine v et bon retour en
france parce que je vous joins à la
luciole en ce moment pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]